YUJIN NAGASAWA:
Thank you very much.
Thank you for inviting me.
So according to recent
surveys, over 80%
of people in the US and
the UK believe in miracles.
And I think that's very
astonishing because now we
rely on all sorts of
scientific technology
like smartphones, computers,
and other scientific tools.
So why do we still
believe in miracles?
So first of all,
I'd like to find out
why we still
believe in miracles,
and whether it is rational
to believe in miracles.
So let me start
with some examples.
So this woman was making
a toasted cheese sandwich.
And then she realized
that there was
a burn pattern on a slice
of toast which looked,
according to her, just
like the Virgin Mary.
And she thought that
this was a miracle
so she kept it in
a plastic container
for more than 10 years.
And meanwhile, she won a
lot of money at the casino.
So she thought that this
is a miraculous object.
But for some reason, she
decided to sell it on eBay.
And she managed to
earn $28,000, which
is probably more miraculous
than this object itself.
Should we say that
this is a miracle?
I think the answer is
no, because this is just
a coincidence.
Given that millions
of slices of toast
are made around the
world, it's not a surprise
that occasionally we see
this kind of strange pattern.
What about this case?
This is another example
of a coincidence.
So in 1950, there was a massive
explosion at the local church
in Nebraska.
And when the
explosion took place,
everyone thought
that a lot of people
were killed because they
were supposed to have
a meeting of the church choir.
But surprisingly,
every single member
had a trivial reason to
be late for the meeting
only on that day.
So these members are
always very punctual.
But only on this day
everyone had a trivial reason
to be late for the meeting.
So for example, one of
them was on the phone
and she just forgot
about the meeting.
Another one was
listening to the radio
and she couldn't turn it off.
Another one was writing
an important letter
and she forgot about
the meeting as well.
So they had all sorts
of silly reasons
to be late for the meeting.
And then there was
this massive explosion.
And of course, they
thought this is a miracle,
because no one was hurt.
So they thought that God saved
them from this explosion.
But I would still say
that this is not exactly
a miracle, at least in
a philosophical sense,
because given that there
are billions of people
on this planet doing all
sorts of things every day,
occasionally we encounter this
kind of unusual coincidence.
But it is difficult
for us to say
that this is a miracle in the
philosophical or theological
sense.
So here I would like to
introduce three different types
of impossibility.
So certain events are
probabilistically impossible.
So these coincidences
are probabilistically
impossible or unlikely.
But these events can take
place, unless the probability
of these events taking
place is exactly zero.
So again, given that there are
so many people around the world
doing so many different
things, occasionally
these probabilistically
unlikely or impossible events
can take place.
So I think miracles cannot be
probabilistically impossible.
Miracles have to involve
some kind of impossibility,
but it cannot be a
probabilistic impossibility.
It has to be something
stronger than
probabilistic impossibility.
So what about logical
impossibility?
So certain acts are logically
impossible to perform.
So for example, it is
logically impossible to draw
a square circle or
create a married bachelor
or make one plus one five.
So they are logically
impossible tasks.
So it is necessarily impossible
to perform these tasks.
Now, I think this is a
little bit too strong.
We cannot say that miracles
are logically impossible tasks,
because miracles are
supposed to happen.
But if it is necessarily
impossible as a matter of logic
to perform these tasks, then
they cannot be performed.
So even theistic philosophers
often claim that God cannot
perform logically
impossible tasks,
because these logically
impossible tasks are not real
tasks.
They sound like tasks,
but actually no one
can perform it in any
possible situation.
So that means that they
are not authentic tasks.
So what we need is
something between
probabilistic impossibility
and logical impossibility.
So my suggestion is that
miracles are nomologically
impossible events, which means
that miracles cannot take place
given the laws of nature.
So our universe is governed
by the laws of nature.
And when they are violated,
these miracle workers
can perform miracles.
So this is a typical
philosophical definition
of a miracle.
A miracle is a violation
of the laws of nature
that is caused by
an intentional agent
and it has religious
significance.
So a miracle has to be
caused by some agent like God
or an angel who have
free will and intention.
And also they have to have
some religious significance.
So normally, miracles
have positive outcomes.
It would be a little bit odd to
say a miracle has taken place,
but it's really bad.
So normally, miracles
have some positive impact.
And most importantly,
miracles have
to violate the laws of nature.
So this is the key
feature of miracles.
So if you look at many examples
in religious scriptures,
then you can see that they all
violate the laws of nature.
So for example,
Jesus is reported
to have resurrected Lazarus, who
had been dead for several days.
And we cannot resurrect someone
who had been dead for many days
without violating
the laws of nature.
Or Jesus is reported
to have walked on water
or transformed water into wine.
And they all require violations
of the laws of nature.
And miracles are also reported
in religious scriptures
in the East.
So for example, the
Buddha, when he was born,
he immediately walked
seven steps north.
And then he said, I
am chief of the world.
And again, without violating
the laws of nature,
it is impossible
for a newborn baby
to walk and speak like this.
So that's why we can say
that this is a miracle.
Now, there are many
different types of miracles.
So there are so many, but I'd
like to introduce some of them.
Producing substances.
So for instance,
Mohammad is believed
to have filled an empty well or
filled an empty bag of barley
for a hungry man.
Controlling weather.
So Jesus, according
to the New Testament,
Jesus rebuked a fierce
rainstorm on the Sea of Galilee.
Controlling the
sun and the moon.
Mohammad for
example, is believed
to have changed the
movement of the sun
or split the moon in two.
Controlling
geographical features.
So according to
the Old Testament,
in response to
Moses' request, God
parted the Red Sea so
that Moses and his people
can escape from
the Egyptian army.
Teleportation and bilocation.
Many Hindu saints and
gurus are reported
to have appeared in two
places at the same time
or teleported from one
location to another instantly.
Transfiguration.
According to the New Testament,
Jesus transfigured himself
on a mountain.
So he suddenly became
a very strong light,
which is understood to
represent his heavenly glory.
Stigmata is well known in
the Catholic tradition.
So this includes
all sorts of scars
that appear on people's bodies
that correspond to the wounds
that Jesus had.
So this is a symbolic miracle.
Healing is also very
widely reported in almost
in all religious traditions.
So Jesus, Mohammad, and
the Buddha and so on,
all of these leaders of
the world's great religion
are believed to have healed
sick people, often instantly.
Raising the dead.
So as I mentioned,
Jesus is believed
to have resurrected dead people.
And there are similar episodes
in the Old Testament as well.
Supernatural perception includes
precognition, retro-cognition,
and mind reading.
So these miracle
workers, they can
predict what will happen
in future exactly,
or they can immediately grasp
what happened in the past.
Or they can read people's
minds accurately.
Controlling immaterial spirits.
Probably the best
example is exorcism.
So exorcism is a
religious practice
to evict an evil spirit
that is possessing a human.
So if you remember the
film "The Exorcist,"
the priest tries to evict
an evil spirit from a girl.
Spiritual communication
includes all sorts of ways
for a supernatural being,
supernatural beings
to communicate with people.
So sometimes these
beings appear in dreams,
and sometimes they appear
in religious experiences,
as apparitions, as ghosts.
Now, what I find very
interesting is that many
of these leaders of the world's
great religions-- like Jesus,
the Buddha,
Mohammad, and so on--
they are reported to have
performed miracles themselves.
But at the same
time, they are not
particularly enthusiastic
about miracles.
So they warn against
dependence on miracles,
which I find very puzzling.
So for example, the
Buddha met a yogi one day
who was trying to walk on
water for several years.
And then the Buddha
said, why do you do this?
This is just a waste of
time, because you can just
take a ferry for a
small change to go
to the other side of the river.
So you are just
wasting your time.
Or in the New Testament, Jesus
was challenged by the devil.
And the devil says that you
have to turn rocks into bread
or jump off from a high
temple without getting hurt.
And then Jesus simply refused.
If Jesus was a miracle
worker, then of course,
he could have performed
these miracles.
But he simply refused, which
is quite interesting and also
puzzling.
But I would like to come back to
this point a little bit later.
So as I said earlier, according
to recent surveys, many people,
the majority of people
still believe in miracles.
And I would like to explain why.
Because again, we rely
on scientific knowledge
and technology, but still
we believe in something
beyond science.
And why is that?
My hypothesis is that there
are some psychological reasons
that people tend to
form belief in miracles.
So there are some cognitive
and developmental reasons
that people form
belief in miracles.
So let me introduce some
psychological studies
that are relevant here.
So according to some
developmental psychologists,
even infants can
detect violations
of the laws of nature.
So again, miracles have
to involve violations
of the laws of nature.
This means that in order to
detect a miracle, first of all,
you have to know what
the laws of nature are,
how nature is operated
according to the laws,
and also you have to be
able to grasp it immediately
when they are violated.
And this sounds like a very
sophisticated cognitive
process, but according
to some psychologists,
even 2.5-month-old babies can
detect violations of the laws
of nature.
So for example,
they show a toy lion
to children-- babies-- that
appear to vanish suddenly,
or a toy car that appears
to hover in the air.
And then these babies,
they express surprise.
And sometimes they
bang these toys
to see how that could happen.
Or sometimes they try to
duplicate these violations
of the laws of nature.
So this suggests that
they have innate knowledge
of the laws of nature, and
when they are violated,
they can immediately grasp it.
So it looks like we have
this natural tendency
to see violations of
the laws of nature.
And these developmental
psychologists,
they say that this
element of surprise
is very important for
children's learning process.
Another relevant
psychological study
here is a detection of
agents, faces, and voices.
So some psychologists
claim that we
are good at scanning
our environment
and then find agency there.
So relevant concept here is the
hyperactive agency detection
device.
So this is a cognitive device.
It's not a material device,
but it's a cognitive device
that everyone has.
So when we see the
clouds in the sky,
we might see strange
faces or animals.
And that's because we all
have the hyperactive agency
detection device.
So we are good at
finding agency in nature.
So here's an example.
So this is the face on Mars.
This is a geological
structure on Mars,
which appears to be a face.
It's very difficult for
us not to see a face,
even though this
structure looks quite
different from different angles.
And sometimes this
kind of phenomenon
is called pareidolia, which is
a psychological phenomenon where
we see something meaningful
in random information.
According to
psychologists, we also
detect the intention
of agents in nature.
So if you ask small children
why rocks are pointy
or why the sunlight
is warm, they
tend to provide
teleological explanations.
They tend to explain
these natural phenomena
in terms of purpose.
So they might say rocks are
pointy so that the birds cannot
sit down on them, or, the
sunlight is warm so that it can
warm up animals.
So they appeal to
purpose when they try
to explain natural phenomena.
And adults have this
kind of tendency as well.
So maybe that's why when we
encounter unusual events,
we might intuitively
think that this
is caused by God or
some supernatural
being with intention.
Children are also good at
detecting supernatural beings.
So they tend to attribute
supernatural properties
to humans as well.
So the Swiss psychologist
Piaget, Jean Piaget,
he interviewed many children.
And he discovered that
they tend to attribute
these unusual supernatural
properties to adults.
So for example, he talks about
a girl who asked her aunt
to make it rain,
or a boy who was
puzzled when his father
didn't know something.
So children tend to attribute
the properties of omniscience
or omnipotence to adults.
Maybe that's another
indirect reason
that people and
especially children
tend to see something
supernatural in nature.
Minimally
counterintuitive concepts.
This is also relevant to the
psychological work related
to supernatural beliefs.
According to some psychologists,
well-known miracle stories,
they involve so-called minimally
counterintuitive concepts.
So these are concepts
that are somewhat
surprising and counterintuitive
and contradictory,
but they are not
overly contradictory.
And this concept
spreads very well,
because it's very easy to
remember these stories,
because they have some
counterintuitive elements.
But at the same
time, they are not
difficult to remember
because these stories are
pretty straightforward, only
minimally counterintuitive.
So here's an example.
So about 100 years ago
there was a girl called
Okiku in Hokkaido, Japan.
And one day, her father
bought her this little doll.
And Okiku loved
the doll very much.
And she played with it every day
and slept with it every night.
But sadly, Okiku passed away
after a couple of years.
And after her death,
people realized
that the hair of
the doll had grown.
And they thought that
this is because Okiku
loved the doll so much that
her spirit possessed this doll.
That's why the hair had grown.
And this is a good example of
a minimally counterintuitive
concept.
The whole story is pretty
straightforward and easy
to remember.
But at the same time, there's
one catchy counterintuitive
element, which is the
growing hair of the doll.
And according to
psychologists, stories
like this spread very
well and they last
for a long time over
many generations.
And if you see many
miracle episodes
in religious scriptures, such as
Jesus turning water into wine,
or walking on water, or
resurrecting the dead,
they all involve minimally
counterintuitive concepts.
So we have seen various
psychological studies
that seem to suggest
that we are cognitively
biased towards forming
belief in miracles.
But that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's always
irrational to
believe in miracles,
or miracles can
never take place.
Here is a parallel example.
So suppose that
psychologists discover
that I tend to see an illusion
of a can of beer in my fridge
when I'm very thirsty.
Now I go home and
open my fridge,
and I see a can of beer.
Does that mean that
I'm seeing an illusion?
That's not so obvious.
Maybe I bought a can
of beer last night
and that's why it's there.
So even if we have
this natural tendency
to form belief in miracles,
that doesn't necessarily
mean that miracles
can never take place,
or every time when we encounter
miracles, they are illusions.
That's why I'd like to
address this question next.
Is it rational to
believe in miracles?
Carl Sagan was an American
astronomer and science fiction
writer.
And he introduced
this famous slogan,
"Extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence."
So he says that in
order to establish
something
extraordinary, you have
to have extraordinary evidence.
So suppose that my friend says
that he saw a fox in his garden
last night.
Now, I know that this
friend is very trustworthy,
and he almost never lies.
And also I know that foxes have
been observed in his village.
And I have pretty good reason
to believe that he has actually
seen a fox in his garden.
But suppose instead, he
says that he saw a Martian
in his garden last night.
Can we believe that on the
basis of similar evidence?
No, because now his new
claim is extraordinary.
He says that he saw a Martian.
That's an extraordinary
claim, so we
need extraordinary
evidence to believe him.
David Hume is a Scottish
philosopher, the 18th century
Scottish philosopher.
And he appealed to
a similar reasoning
to show that it is always
unreasonable to believe
in miracles, or we
can never be justified
in believing in miracles.
So here is a summary
of his argument.
So he says, gather as
much evidence as possible
for a miracle.
It can never be strong enough
to establish your belief,
because evidence
against a miracle
is always much, much
bigger, because again,
according to our
definition, a miracle
is a violation of
the laws of nature,
which means that any
evidence against a miracle
includes the entire
laws of nature.
But there is nothing more
certain than the laws
of nature, because
the laws of nature
are based on constant
observations of how
nature operates.
So no matter how much evidence
we gather for a miracle,
that's never strong enough
to establish our belief
in miracles.
That's Hume's argument.
So he says that that is
always unreasonable to believe
in miracles, or it is we
can never be justified
in believing in miracles.
But again, I want to emphasize
that this does not necessarily
mean that miracles
can never take place.
All he says is that even if
a miracle can take place,
there is no situation in which
we are justified in believing
that it has taken place.
So at this point, I
would like to consider
if there can be a
miracle that doesn't
involve a violation
of the laws of nature.
So I want to focus on what I
call extremely altruistic act.
An extremely altruistic
act is an act
to sacrifice one's own life
to save a stranger's life.
So let me introduce
some examples.
So in 1982, Florida
Air Flight 90
took off from Washington
National Airport,
and the weather was
really terrible.
There was a snowstorm.
And then the aircraft
couldn't gain altitude,
and it smashed into
a frozen river there.
And most of the
passengers were killed,
and only a very small
number of them survived.
And a rescue helicopter came
and they threw a life ring.
And you can find footage of
this incident on the web.
And it's really heartbreaking.
It's very difficult
to rescue them
because they are so cold
that they even struggled
to grab the life ring.
And at one point, a bystander
jumped into the frozen river
to rescue one of the passengers.
That's also an act of altruism.
And then one of the
passengers who survived
was Arland D. Williams Jr.
And every time a life ring was
thrown, he grabbed
it, and then hand it
to a different passenger
instead of using it for himself.
And eventually these
passengers were rescued.
And then the
helicopter went back
to rescue finally Williams,
but he was already gone.
So this is an act of what I call
extreme altruism because this
is an act to prioritize other
people's lives, stranger's
lives, and sacrifice
one's own life.
Here's another example.
Maximilian Kolbe
was a Polish priest
in the first half
of the 20th century.
He was sent to the
Auschwitz death camp.
And one day,
another prisoner was
selected to be sent to
a starvation bunker.
And he cried and
screamed, saying,
I have a wife and a
child and I cannot die.
I don't want to be sent
to a starvation bunker.
And then Kolbe came
in and he said,
I'd like to replace this man.
I would like to substitute
him, because I'm a priest
and I don't have a family.
So send me instead of him
to the starvation bunker.
And he survived in
the starvation bunker
for a long time.
But eventually he
was killed there.
And this is another example of
an extremely altruistic act.
And I talk about
extremely altruistic acts
because they are not
exactly miracles,
but they do something
similar to that.
Extremely altruist acts
evoke awe and surprise
because they violate, through
the altruistic person's
own willpower, a
strong behavioral trait
that humans have acquired
through the long process
of evolution.
So these acts don't
violate the laws of nature,
but they still violate
our behavioral trait
to prioritize our own survival.
So we have developed
this kind of trait
through the long
process of evolution
and natural selection.
So our biological
interest should
be to survive and
propagate our own genes.
But these altruists, they
sacrifice their own survival
to save others.
So there is something
contradictory.
It's not exactly a violation
of the laws of nature,
but something
comparable to that.
Now, there are many
scientific theories
to explain away altruism.
So there are animals
that act altruistically.
And biologists try to explain
how that could happen.
So for example, group
selection theory
says that natural
selection can take place
at the level of a group
instead of individuals.
Or kin selection theory
says that sometimes it
is genetically beneficial
to act altruistically
towards genetically
related individuals.
Or reciprocation theory
says that some animals,
even if they are in
different species,
they act altruistically because
these altruistic acts are
mutually beneficial, and so on.
But none of these
theories can explain away
extremely altruistic acts
because these acts are
one-off events where there
is no evolutionary or genetic
advantage for the altruists.
Shusaku Endo was a
Japanese Christian author.
And he wrote a novel
called "Silence."
And Martin Scorsese made a film
based on this novel recently.
And Endo talks about Kolbe.
And I think his remark is quite
interesting and relevant here.
So he says, "I would
not think of it
as a miracle if bread had
suddenly fallen from heaven
or lights from heaven had
blinded the Nazi officials when
the priest was sent to
a starvation bunker.
What is important
is the fact that
to save the crying young
man in front of him,
Kolbe said without
a sense of despair,
'I don't have a wife or
a child as I'm a priest.
Let me substitute him,'
and voluntarily went
to the starvation
bunker only to die.
I want to say that this
fact is a miracle."
So Endo is not a
philosopher, so he
doesn't know the philosophical
definition of a miracle.
But what he says is this.
So Kolbe couldn't violate
the laws of nature
because he was an
ordinary human.
But because of that, he
acted altruistically.
So if he had a
supernatural power,
then maybe he could have just
produced food in the starvation
bunker, or he could have
just killed Nazi officials
to save other prisoners.
But he couldn't do that.
And because he couldn't do
that, he sacrificed his own life
to save a stranger's life.
And that is what's
remarkable about his act.
So somewhat
paradoxically, Kolbe's act
is religiously significant
because he couldn't violate
the laws of nature, because he
wasn't a supernatural being who
can go beyond the
laws of nature.
So extremely
altruistic acts could
be considered as miraculous
as, or possibly even more so
than what we have defined as
miracles, because they do not
violate the laws of nature.
So Hume's argument
against the reasonableness
of believing in
miracles, that's based
on the idea that miracles always
violate the laws of nature.
But extremely
altruistic acts are not
vulnerable to Hume's
argument because they don't
violate the laws of nature.
Now, earlier I said that
the leaders of the world's
great religions, they warned
against dependence on miracles.
So they are not very
enthusiastic about people
trying to perform miracles.
And I think now the
reason is pretty clear.
Violating the laws of
nature is impressive,
but it does not in itself
make one's act worthwhile.
So it's very easy
to impress people
by violating the laws of nature,
because they are like magic.
It's very easy to
impress people.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
that your act is
meaningful because you
violate the laws of nature.
There are many other acts, such
as Kolbe's and Williams's, that
do not violate the
laws of nature,
but they do something
comparable to that,
and these acts are
more worthwhile.
So I think these
religious leaders,
they wanted people to focus
on these worthwhile acts.
And they didn't want to focus
on a unique feature of a miracle
as a violation of
the laws of nature.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Thank you, Yujin.
We've got a few
minutes for questions
if anyone has any questions.
You'll have to give me a minute
to get to you with the mic.
AUDIENCE: I'll start.
I have a question.
Do you think it's possible to
predict when miracles might
be perceived, say,
when people are
in a particular state
of consciousness
or their circumstances,
such they
might want to see miracles?
YUJIN NAGASAWA: So when
people want to see miracles--
are you just asking
that they tend
to see miracles because they
expect for a miracle to happen?
Yeah, I think that kind of
bias can play an important role
in people's formation
of belief in miracles.
So yes, according to
psychology, people
tend to have certain
expectations,
such as confirmation bias.
So suppose that I say that
these days, a lot of people
wear red shirts.
And then you tend to
confirm a lot of examples.
Because now you focus on
people wearing a red shirt.
And then you think it's, oh,
actually, your hypothesis
is right.
Everyone wears a red shirt now.
And that's an example
of cognitive bias.
And I think that kind of thing
can happen when people form
a belief in miracle as well.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if you
think there is any difficulty
around labeling somebody else's
act as being an altruistic
act without being
privy to kind of the inside
of that person's head?
I guess there could
be any reason why
they decide to perform this
action that objectively
is altruistic.
YUJIN NAGASAWA: Right.
Altruism is a very tricky notion
because whatever altruists do,
you can always provide an
ad hoc explanation of why
they perform in that way.
So in the case of
Kolbe, for example,
you could say that he just
wanted to sacrifice his life so
that he can go to heaven.
Or he had some interest
to act out altruistically,
so he's not a genuine altruist.
So I think for any
altruistic act,
we can always provide
an ad hoc explanation.
So it's very difficult
to establish.
Unless you act
altruistically, it's
very difficult to show
that people's acts are
truly altruistic.
So some people say that the
notion of altruism itself
is somehow self-contradictory.
And I think it's true
that Kolbe, in one sense,
he wanted to sacrifice his life.
So in a way his
wish was granted.
But that doesn't
really undermine
his altruistic intention.
Because it's not as if he
wanted to sacrifice himself
because that's pleasurable for
him, or anything like that.
I think he wanted to
sacrifice his life so
that the other prisoner
would be saved.
So I think we could still say
that his act was altruistic.
But as you suggested, unless you
can see the inside of his head,
it's quite difficult to say what
kind of exact intention he had.
AUDIENCE: You said at the
beginning of the lecture
that about 80% of people in this
country believe in miracles.
But I think only about 49%
of people believe in God.
So do you think
that says anything
interesting about
whatever it is,
the 30-odd percent
of people that
don't believe in any
divine agency, but do
believe in miracles?
YUJIN NAGASAWA: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So often belief in
miracles is more
widespread than belief in God.
But normally, we assume
that only religious people
believe in miracles.
And I think maybe
one of the reasons
is that the concept of a miracle
is not defined precisely.
So these surveys,
when they ask people
if they believe
in miracles, they
don't provide a specific
definition of a miracle.
So sometimes people have in
mind some unusual coincidences
or some amazing events.
So they might not
necessarily have
in mind a violation of
the laws of nature that
can be only performed by God
or some supernatural beings.
So I think maybe
one of the reasons
is that the term miracle
can be quite vague.
So I think if you want
to conduct a survey,
I think it's quite important
to specify exactly what you
mean by a miracle.
MODERATOR: Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm interested to know
if the incidence of miracles
is declining, or is
it remains static?
And if there are any kind of
more recent examples which
you've looked up and
have you stumped?
YUJIN NAGASAWA: Yes, according
to one survey that I read,
actually younger people
believe in miracles
more than older people.
And many of them
claim that they know
someone who has experienced
a miracle, which
I find quite surprising.
Because if you are old,
then you have more time
to experience a miracle.
But actually younger people,
they believe in miracles
more than the older people.
And if you look at
newspapers and magazines,
there are a lot of
examples of miracles,
but often they are
just coincidences
or some unexpected events.
Even in sports, people
talk about miracles.
And they are not miracles
in the religious sense.
And these days, we don't really
see amazing religious miracles
that are reported in the
religious scriptures.
But maybe they are still
taking place somewhere,
and we just don't
know about them.
AUDIENCE: It's more of
an observation, really.
I'll probably make more sense
after I've read the book.
But I think we've almost
lost the vocabulary
for looking into and expressing
anything that's a little bit
strange, outside the remit of
faith or logic or whatever.
If weird things happen to
you, it's probably best
not to talk about them.
And I think maybe we've kind
of lost that collectively.
Virgin Mary on toast aside.
So I'm looking forward
to reading this.
YUJIN NAGASAWA:
So many people who
have religious
experiences, they tend
not to tell about it to anyone.
They tend to be quite reserved
about their experiences, which
is quite interesting.
Because when you have a
strange experience, normally,
you would want to tell someone.
But when it comes to religious
or mystical experiences,
they tend to keep them secret,
which is quite interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But in your case, it's
just a bit [INAUDIBLE],,
it's a bit weird in person.
It's kind of [INAUDIBLE]
right, I'm sure.
YUJIN NAGASAWA: So do you
think that if you experience
a miracle, you might think that
this is a little bit crazy.
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
experience a miracle,
but I think that's probably
healthy [INAUDIBLE],,
but something strange
and inexplicable,
and if you consider yourself
to be a very rational person,
and something strange
happens [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Do you
consider [INAUDIBLE]??
YUJIN NAGASAWA: So miracles are
by definition, weird events.
And if you experience
something really,
really weird,
actually you might not
want to tell anyone
because it's so strange,
and you don't want people
to think that you're crazy.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for your talk.
So you mentioned earlier
that young people
would be more inclined
to believe in miracles.
And actually, it's an easier
way to explain things to them.
So is that a good
thing, or should we--
how do you strike the balance
between explaining things
with miracles and then versus
explaining rational things?
It's mentioned the ant
could make rain happen.
So how do we start to strike
the balance between where
I tell them, oh yeah,
actually someone
decides to make it rain.
Or we say, actually, no.
This is how it works.
This is how the weather works?
YUJIN NAGASAWA: So when I say
that the belief in miracles
is more common
among young people,
I didn't mean small children.
I meant young adults.
Obviously, if you ask
children, probably many of them
believe in what
we call a miracle.
Because according to some
cognitive scientists,
children naturally
form religious beliefs.
So they even say that if
you put a group of children
on a remote island, they will
start their own religion.
They form religious
beliefs naturally
because there are some cognitive
and evolutionary reasons
to form these beliefs.
But the survey that I read
was about young adults.
And then they seemed
to believe in miracles
more than older people, which
I find quite puzzling, I think.
But you could say that
young people, maybe they
haven't had a lot of
experience in life,
so maybe when they
encounter unusual events,
they just attribute it to
something beyond nature.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
So you talked about how
there's religious significance
with a miracle.
So I presume with
most known religions,
there's some sort
of governing group
that observe evidence,
or at least the stories
behind miracles, and then
decides as a collective group
whether that's a miracle or not.
I presume that's a common
function of every religion,
and I'd love to know if not.
And are there sort of common
behaviors within these groups
that observe the evidence
and decide whether they
are miracles or not, are
there sometimes interesting
divergence in approaches?
YUJIN NAGASAWA: Yeah,
so obviously, miracles
are very important
in Christianity
because Jesus' birth was
miraculous and after his death,
there was the
Resurrection, which
is a very important
part of Christianity.
And in the Catholic
tradition, there
is a very rigorous process
of proving whether miracles
have taken place.
And that's important for
the process of canonization.
So Mother Teresa was canonized
a couple of years ago.
And that was based on
her posthumous miracles
that allegedly she performed.
So she cured a Brazilian
man who had brain tumors.
And another person-- I
forgot what kind of condition
she had-- but arguably,
she cured two people
and healed two people.
And on the basis of these
miracles, she was canonized.
So in the Catholic
tradition especially,
miracles are very important.
But my impression is that in
the Eastern tradition, Buddhism
and Hinduism and so on,
miracles are not that important,
at least not as important
as in Christianity.
MODERATOR: Any more questions?
Thank you very much, Yujin.
That was very interesting.
YUJIN NAGASAWA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]